good morning hickets tuesday today i
would like to tell you my least
relatable story so back in 2015 nat
wolfe cara de levine and i traveled to
eight countries in the span of two weeks
to promote the paper towns movie this
was often quite fun because not in cara
are lovely people but to be honest press
junkets are a little excruciating what
happens is they put you in the bowels of
some incredibly nice hotel and then you
sit in front of hot lights for several
hours while every eight minutes a
different reporter comes in and asks you
questions you do this every day for many
days now as jobs go this is not the
hardest one i've ever had but if you
accidentally say something stupid you
can cause a lot of trouble not just for
yourself but for everyone who worked on
the movie and this happens all the time
during press junkets and so for me at
least it was like this weird mix of
absolute monotony and complete terror
okay so we were only in paris for like
18 hours and we saw very little of the
city except that they like drove us to
the eiffel tower for a ridiculous photo
shoot that included this picture that
sarah insisted on framing but most of
those 18 hours were spent in the hotel
where my room was significantly nicer
than my actual house and also cost more
per night than four months of my
mortgage like i said not a super
relatable story so nat and i are sitting
in this windowless room of this
incredibly nice hotel and there are like
10 people crowded in there camera techs
and sound people and my publicist elise
and people from the studio and of course
nat who keeps reminding me to breathe
and drink water between every interview
but even so the lights are very hot and
the air is very stale and i feel this
pounding spiraling anxiety and so i am
clenching my jaw and after a few hours
of clenching i noticed that one of my
teeth has begun to ache the pain gets
worse and worse until just before a
lunch break i tell the movie people i
have a toothache and then shortly
thereafter the hotel concierge comes in
and says you have tooth pain and i say i
have tooth pain and he says you go to
the dentist then i say i go to the
dentist we only have like 40 minutes for
lunch so elise and i are rushed off to i
don't know somewhere in paris where we
walk through a door and enter what i
guess is a dental office waiting area
except that it looks like a billionaire
bachelor's living room there's a cow
skin rug and 19th century paintings on
the wall and designer furniture and this
glass coffee table that has some regular
magazines fanned out across it but also
issues of both playboy and playgirl
elise and i are both trying to figure
out if this is some kind of parisian
fever dream when a guy comes up on a
motorcycle walks in unzips his leather
jacket pulls off his helmet and then
shakes out the most gorgeous head of
hair you can imagine and then elise and
i both audibly gasp because this isn't
just the best looking dentist i've ever
seen he's the best looking person i've
ever seen so this parisian dentist with
impossible levels of facial symmetry
ushers me into an exam room where he
takes some x-rays and taps around the
tooth that hurts and then after a while
he says you have two pains the physical
pain and the psychological pain and then
with the drill he slightly reshapes the
tooth that hurts so that i'm not
clenching down on just it and tells me
to stop clenching my jaw i return to the
press junket i breathe i drink water i
don't quench my jaw as much and i feel
better in retrospect the parisian
dentist was the first sign that a
psychological storm was brewing that
would eventually derail my life for a
while and it's not like going to a fancy
dentist saved me from that fate still he
was a good dentist what is the moral of
this story i guess it's a story about
having a need that is capably met by a
compassionate expert which come to think
of it should not be an unrelatable story
at all my hope for you is that your
needs will be met by a compassionate
expert i think that's something that we
all deserve so thank you to that
compassionate expert in paris how did he
afford those fancy impressionist
paintings on the wall was he like a
billionaire who sidewided as a dentist
like he was a dentist for the love of
the game or was he like a wildly
successful dentist who charges like a
hundred thousand dollars for a hand on
the shoulder and uh you have two kinds
of pain the physical pain and the
psychological pain i'll never know but
we'll always have paris doctor i can't
remember your name we'll always have
paris
hank i'll see you on friday